[Music]
what do you call a purple cat let me
check on that it's called a clowder of
cat if you have a question any question
there's a number you can call nine one
seven two seven five six nine seven five
and the librarian at the New York Public
Library will try to answer it for you
hello thanks for calling ask NYPL we
have ten librarians on a team and we
answer any question that you may have
over the telephone in the office today
we have Matthew Barnard Sarina Diane and
me our department asked NYPL
began in 1967 we started answering
questions over the telephone but people
have been reaching out to librarians for
as long as there has been libraries the
New York Public Library has actually
saved records of some of the more
interesting questions they've been asked
over the years like if they're full moon
every night Acapulco
why do 18th century English paintings
have so many squirrels in them and how
to detain them so they wouldn't fight
the painter our Plato Aristotle and
Socrates one in the same person in a
world of Google it's a bit surprising to
know that they get around 30,000 calls
per year my question is why oftentimes
people might not have access to the
technology at home and I honestly think
some just want somebody to toss this so
the next time you have a question like
how many teeth does a great white shark
have you can call this number nine one
seven two seven five six nine seven five
that will ring inside of this building
up on this floor and maybe Bernard or
Rosa will pick up and they'll answer it
for you
they have about three hundred serrated
teeth
[Music]
this library is full of historic
treasures the Trinity library in Dublin
Ireland was founded in 1592 its most
famous area is the Long Room this 213
foot room houses 200,000 of the
library's oldest books the room is lined
with marble busts many of great
philosophers writers and people who
supported the college the long room is
also home to one of the last remaining
copies of the 1916 proclamation of the
Irish Republic the Trinity College harp
which is from the 15th century and the
Book of Kells an illuminated manuscript
of the four Gospels that is from the
eighth century it is the largest library
in Ireland and as a copyright library it
contained books and materials published
in Ireland for free it is the only
library in the country to hold this
right in fingering Wisconsin there is a
house on a rock but it is so much more
than that
inside it is home to many bizarre and
incredible collections there's a room of
self playing instruments an infinity
room a giant squid attacking a whale and
some nightmare-inducing dolls it seems
like a really strange Museum and that's
because no it appears to be a museum
because it is housing antiques it's
housing all kinds of memorabilia and
things from a different era it's more of
a place to just enjoy so what is house
on the rug the house on the rock to me
is a magical complex an all-around
century explosion it was made by Alex
Jordan who was an architect not at all
not at all he is not a trained man he's
just a man of great vision maybe not an
architect but an evident hoarder
Alex Jordan with the help of his friends
built the house on the rock in the 40's
and opened it to the public in 60 his
collections of antiques and junk new
items and old real and quite obviously
fake have no central theme or apparent
reason for being there and maybe that's
part of its charm there are some pretty
incredible things including a huge
unraidable carousel 269 different
animals not one of them is a horse
really yes
the horses are drawing the walls of
course they do you know every time you
turn the corner here it's a different
thing and it's a different Wow and you
don't know what to expect one man's
trash is another man's roadside tourist
attraction
[Music]
in southern Pennsylvania there is a
battlefield a battlefield so important
that it is thought to be the turning
point of the American Civil War this is
a story about that place it's also a
story about cats thousands and thousands
of little cats
[Music]
this is Rebecca hi I'm Rebecca and this
is her twin sister Ruth hi I'm Ruth and
we run a museum of dioramas that are
made with a handmade Civil War cat Civil
War cats the combination of a childhood
love for clay cats and a strong
fascination with the American Civil War
it started out as a hobbies that we just
did as kids puffing around in our
bedroom that bit of child's play led to
a full-fledged museum which opened in
2013
the two of us discussed how much do we
want to emphasize the cat thing because
we don't want to come off as cutesy cats
the idea is the stories of the men not
so much the fact that they're cats they
just are cats because they're cat
incredibly each of these beans is to
scale 1/8 of an inch equals one foot in
cat feet and so each one of our soldiers
represents one soldier who would have
been on the field we'll calculate the
numbers that would have been left in the
regiment and we'll fill it in with that
many cats filters so for example little
round tops we're going to eventually
have about 5,000 soldiers on it
typically one like the angle we figure
took us about four and a half years he
Little Round Top diorama we figure is
more of a five or six year diorama oh we
really just want to make the savour more
approachable I guess for people so they
can relate to the history and have more
of a connection with the men and the
women involved now that the word of the
sentence out all of the people who love
cats come in and now not only are they
seeing our dioramas of falling in love
with the five and a half thousand little
furry smiles smiling at them but they're
also learning the stories and some leads
they have an appreciation of Gettysburg
and the history just because they came
to see the cat in the 80s when lots of
people were playing arcade games like
pac-man Donkey Kong and Frogger this is
what they were playing in Soviet Russia
[Music]
this treacherous pitiless fear Roderich
mosquitoes area grab another bottle
that's Alexander
he runs the Museum of Soviet arcade
machine in st. Petersburg Russia
[Music]
hadiyyah-lah movie Invictus approach at
course - vodka mania Oh Misha Kotik
ostinatos Pascale's watch - another
instruction in the military version of
punishable extremely fast Cheney in
Moscow with 15 video unlike their
Western counterparts the games weren't
just for fun touch children Arabic of
Sevilla gross tomahto
we still miss public key the automatic
Ithorian me cousin back roughly count
our life as a Zoe without subjugation
the point of the game with training to
the Soviet Army building skills like
reasoning and eye coordination and
marksmanship stimulus of catalog order
second phase my photographer Thomas
Yossi Pierre Trudeau who chose enemies
of ellebra live samipya yamamoto
prejudice is Suwannee of electronica
where's Moses Mohammed Meah to punish
him
h-he neo-assyrian Amalia Sophia Bush
McGraw conney
all the Soviet arcade games were built
in military factories using leftover
parts from weapons refrigerators
calculators and other items sister
obstructions like visual indication is
positive identity - still so very very
honest traumatic story boxer media
Rossmann logic adapted over make
breakfast criminal - really
but now decades after the fall of the
Soviet Union profane irritability
isolating Russia modere privado Bremen
Villa California Las Cruces circumcised
own representatives in grams
[Music]
will you tell people that I run their
black car
they got luck what's that I never heard
of that before
when they first do it they go wow this
is fun
I am buzz Frank Perry I am the
proprietor of buzzer AMA the slot car
racing center of the world lot car
racing is a hobby sport that
participated in all over the world in
1965 it was my hobby I was one of the
first to open in New York there was 48
places like this in the city today Tom
it I'm the lone survivor they have 12
volt DC motors in them and a guide flag
that fits in the slot and when you hint
the hand controller it energizes those
lanes and gives the motor juice the
faces cause can go upwards of 100 miles
an hour so they're like blurs now you
have to hear them your wing wing' you
never see them have to listen to them
you go wow
kids play with computer now and there's
no interaction with anyone over here
they have interaction with other drivers
don't compete they congratulate each
other you learnt sportsmanship is really
great just watching the cause go around
the track pumps up your adrenaline and
you get all excited and that that thrill
never leaves you
you always think about it in Guanajuato
Mexico there is a museum filled entirely
this mummy
[Music]
Ninomiya Salim Arabs like a yo-yo elodie
rector Adel mucho de las manos de
guanajuato el mozo de las Diez de
guanajuato es un resent OSA gyrados
KX is a yuna collection momomiya
naturally with 117 bodies in total the
median has the largest collection of
natural mummy in the world the mummies
of the well-preserved remains of people
who died during a cholera outbreak in
Mexico in the 1800s the museum is a
haunting and eerie experience for
visitors an opportunity to stare death
in the faith
Vienna buskers experiencia intima sa
encuentro místico con la muerte que
propecia la recession in store no a la
intención be de leus NGO de la misma s
importante que las personas no tengo el
nido la muerte yell contrary o lo veo
cómo phenomena natural como una
transición inevitable resistencia porque
finalmente yemeni encontrar Connie
[Music]